Uh, let's go next to our caller from the eight
four, seven area code.
Who's calling today from eight, four, seven.
Hey, David, this is Joe.
I'm calling from Chicago.
Hey Joey.
What's going on?
Okay.
How much man?
It's one of the first, I'll say.
I appreciate your show so much.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
What's you guys everyday anyways, um, so I
want to talk about, uh, social media.
Um, so I forgive me if I ask something that
you already answered and showed that you were
going to die.
You were talking about a lot.
Um, but I watched your temple debate.
Okay.
And so, you know, I'm 32, so I remember when
social media started.
Um, and it's just kind of crazy how it evolved.
And now there's all this debate on obviously
free speech when you know, in reality when
you have a white supremacist or you have somebody
you know, touting antisemetic suffer any,
any racist stuff, any rational person will
be like, okay, that's wrong.
What is, what is stopping, you know, Twitter
or Facebook or whatever from kind of just
being like, you know, not just saying they're
on the left, but just being like, we're not
going to accept this.
You know what I mean?
I don't understand what's stopping you from
saying what to whom?
Well, because I feel like Twitter and like
the bigger social media places are like signed
up trying to, they kind of have to like tiptoe
around.
Yeah.
They're trying to not appear to be making
editorial decisions that are overtly politically
biased.
Right.
And I understand that.
But my question I guess is just what is stopping
them to stopping them from not becoming a
little politically biased?
Okay, so you're saying like, why?
So if Twitter says, yeah, we have a left wing
bent or we have a right wing vent, what, why,
why would that be bad?
Why can't they just do that?
Like it's okay for companies to have political
bents is what you're suggesting?
Yeah.
I mean I think the problem is that these platforms
have gotten so big that if they just say we're
just a liberal company or we're a conservative
company, it will immediately open them up
to more lawsuits than they're already facing
arguments that they should be regulated because
of their size and that it would be inappropriate
that did that, that any limitation on speech
that is politically biased should be handled
as if, uh, they are sort of pseudo government
entities be under these towns square sort
of ideas and provision.
So I think that there are very clear reasons
why they would want to be perceived as not
even if the individuals who run the companies
have personal politics, which of course they
do, why they would want to appear as though
the editorial decisions they make and the
content decisions are not politically biased.
I get why they want to do that.
Yeah.
Like this crazy extent where, you know, obviously
anybody can say whatever they want, but just
to what, like how, how, how demeaning can
you be to a certain group of people and it
just be free speech obviously, you know.
Yes.
Well, I mean from a legal standpoint, we know
where the line is when it comes to the terms
of service of a private company.
Uh, there are more factors to consider including
where the company is drawing the line.
Right.
Cool.
Okay.
Thanks for the call.
Appreciate it.
Yep.
Great to hear from you Joey.
Joey from Chicago.